how to get started
i got a question from one of my youtube
viewers love you guys shane who wrote in
to say
evan i've had this idea i want to create
a website that teaches people how to do
things so if they want to learn how to
ride a bicycle
or learn how to do html or learn how to
fix their car
or learn cooking my website will help
them but he's been on this idea for two
years and hasn't done anything with it
and he wanted my advice
on how to get started shane this is
important and you're in a place that a
lot of entrepreneurs are in you've got
this big idea
you've got a big vision for what it
could be and yet nothing
seems to happen underneath it here's the
key okay this is really important
niche your business and get started on a
small scale
so instead of being this home for
everybody start small pick
one thing that you love
and teach people how to do that i don't
know if you know anything about cooking
or cars or riding the bike you know
if that's not your passion then don't
focus on that to start
focus on something that you're really
good at and you want to help
people learn so if you're a programmer
launch
a course using your format of how to
teach
people how to code right i can come to
your website and learn how to code
just start with that and it builds
momentum for you
it helps build your system it helps
build build some energy up into this so
it's not just this idea that's sitting
on the table
and nothing happens and we all have
these things
like you're not alone a lot of people
have this vision for a company a product
service idea they want to create and
they don't do anything with it
the key is to start small start with a
niche
focus on that and build it up and it's
great to have that big vision i'm not
saying that's what you're going to be
doing forever this one little thing
but that's your stepping stone to future
products and your community can help
take you you start a language
teaching people how to program course
people will take that if you make it
great they're going to love it
and you can use those people to build
future products right you write to them
to finish the course
say hey john thanks so much for taking
the course what did you think
what else would you like to learn it's
like ah you know what i really want to
learn french
build a french course right like these
people can help take you to new markets
but the key is that you've gotten
started by keeping it small
looking at look at facebook as an
example okay facebook how they got
started was just
on college campuses i don't know if mark
zuckerberg
had this vision for what it could become
it would become this big thing as it is
now it doesn't really even matter
he started small on university college
campuses
and it became a phenomenon and it grew
from there
do the same thing for you start small
again one thing that you love doing
make it sizeable so that you can you can
do it yourself right you can actually
finish it
right if it was a course on bicycle
repair
and you don't know anything about
bicycles now becomes this big thing
right you have to go find an expert on
bicycles you have to explain to them
what you're doing you have to go
i mean if you're going to film them
you're going to interview them it's this
whole thing
and all that work you look at it and say
oh that's so much work
and you don't do anything as a result so
pick something that you could do you
could knock this out
you could knock it out in a week because
you know what you're talking about
and put it up and build momentum and
when you see people using it
and loving it and giving you feedback
it's going to give you the drive to keep
going and do another course and another
course and another course and soon that
momentum will be so strong
that you can't help but pour everything
you got into making this business take
off
for me one of the best parts of my day
is every day i wake up and i look at the
comments from you guys that
that gets me excited that keeps me going
i don't know about you but sometimes
you know you'll wake up one day and you
may have been super excited that the day
before
super passionate about something you
wake up the next day it seems to be gone
it's like
where where where was that i gotta aim
myself up again today
and for me that's by looking at your
comments seeing all the comments that
come in every day
keep me going that momentum keeps me
going keeps me making new videos keeps
me invested in new projects it gets me
excited gives me the right puts me in
the right
state of mind first thing in the morning
that's what i want for you to start to
have happen
because if one person leaves feedback on
your course and say hey
this is great thank you so much for
creating this that's
forget about the money you make from
advertising forget about all the work
you put into it just that
that feeling you get from helping
somebody knowing that you
made a difference in that person's life
that's you're going to live off of that
stuff
that's going to make you want to do more
and more and more and more and more so
pick one thing
and get started don't make it a huge
project
believe those are watching like the
video give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think leave a comment you
have a question
leave it below make a video response and
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see more videos like this
thank you so much i'll see you soon
you